i think in general the government is not
good at what it does
um you know it's either incompetent or
ineffective or inefficient
or it's or it's kind of villainous you
know one of the reasons you would ask
how did i become a libertarian and part
of it is after i graduated college
and before i got in the lucrative teen
mag business
i was i wrote for a bunch of newspapers
in new jersey i was a reporter
and i would always have to go to
planning board meetings and like you
know if you want to turn people into
libertarians like just
busload school kid you know bus school
kids to planning board meetings where
people you know just the people in
charge just rail against
anybody who had the temerity to like
improve their land
you know or their house without getting
the right permits and half of the
cases i saw like people didn't even know
like oh i needed to go to the city
council to
put up a fence or like to you know make
my house better
it's like screw you
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the editor at large
of reason magazine and host of the
reason interview
nick gillespie finally welcome to the
reuben report
thanks for having me dave i really
appreciate it so this is very bizarre
for me to admit but we played a clip of
real time with bill maher last week with
heidi heitkamp
uh accusing gina carano of basically
being a nazi and a white supremacist and
you were sitting next uh
heidi heitkamp when she said this and i
played the clip
and then i said oh there's my buddy nick
gillespie from reason magazine four i
think i said former guest of the reuben
report
and then we realized after that we've
never done this somehow and i i feel bad
i usually don't apologize at the
beginning of a show
but i feel bad that you've never been
here before i uh in many contexts i
perform after
i apologize after performance uh
failures so i
uh i please don't apologize i'm happy to
be here i know i've gotten to interview
you twice once for reason and once at uh
students for liberty liberty con so it's
nice to be on the other side of the mic
all right one way or another here we are
it's overdue but we got a lot to get to
but let's
let's start with that clip because i
want to spend a lot of time obviously
talking about
libertarianism and if there's any
differences between libertarianism and
classical liberalism and
what should libertarians do now and all
that good stuff
but since the clip was what got us here
today let's start with that so i'm going
to throw to it right now
who was the woman in the mandalorian
what did she do she liked something
she's a nazi oh that's different right
i'm thinking of somebody else well she's
not a nazi
um she does hang with white supremacy
it's like a mel brooks it does
yeah hangs with whites i suppose i'm not
get subject to defamation
i i don't know i mean it depends on what
your definition of white supremacist is
that you're so
the goal post there changed a lot you
were a guy in a clan hood who
but i think we have to i think we have
to be really careful there's two things
the republicans think they're going to
get biden on
cancel culture and this whole dr seuss
stuff that's going on where they're
reading
green eggs and ham proving that some of
these senators can actually read
and and um and
and immigration and and and so
we can't ignore the fact that we got
donald trump was in part because
of political correctness okay so
there's obviously a bunch to unpack
there and it sort of seems to me by the
by your sort of quick reaction it's like
when you're doing this on live tv
sometimes people say something so over
the top
you kind of don't know how to react can
you just lay out what was going through
your mind during that
uh you know it there were a lot of
moments where
um you know i was kind of looking to my
left and i was like
i this is a former you know u.s
senator and i didn't understand where
she was coming from that was certainly
part of it and uh you know the whole uh
you know
i i grew up in the 70s and 80s and
hogan's heroes and mel brooks movies
were still
you know everywhere and they always were
making fun of nazis
i never thought i would live in america
my father in world war ii fought the
nazis i mean he was in the
you know in europe fighting as an
infantryman i never thought that
people would be seriously lobbying
charges of nazism
just as a way of shutting down all sorts
of conversation what i liked in that
clip
uh or what i liked in the reaction there
is that bill maher
has really stepped up as a massive
defender of free speech and you know and
i disagree with him about a lot of
things i'm sure you do too
but fundamentally what you want in a you
know what you want in
anybody in media certainly and anybody
in any kind of intellectual endeavor to
be pushing for free speech
and i was glad to see him push back in a
way that you know was
was refreshing because and you could see
how i think
heidi in a way is a proxy for a lot of
people
broadly on the left i mean she's
actually a centrist democrat but
where they say well somebody's a nazi
and then it's like no they're not a nazi
they accuse somebody else
of being like the nazis then you know
then it's like well they hang out with
the alt-right then they do this then
they do that and there's almost like
a series of decision trees but it's like
okay not a nazi but then this not this
but then that and
so you know it's a nice encapsulation i
think of a thought process
that is unfortunately rampant in public
discourse right now yeah and you could
sort of see the way she was
laughing and smiling over what she was
saying that she didn't even
believe it or even know what she was
saying in a way i think that second part
is probably
more to the point and and i have to say
you know i enjoy talking with her
uh you know in in some ways if there
were more democrats like her still in
the senate yeah
i don't think we would be seeing the
same level of spending
et cetera having said that i mean it's a
little bit promiscuous to
you know call somebody a nazi and then
not even know who they are or what they
were talking about
and then you know just kind of trail off
into well you know
maybe they're not nazis but they hang
out with people who hang out with people
who
hang out with nazis who aren't really
nazis um you know
enough already yeah it is enough ready
real quick on
on bill maher because i think you said
something interesting there he is what i
would say is
maybe one of the last 10 public
intellectuals or comedians whatever you
want to call them that is offering what
i would say is a liberal
a true liberal defense of free speech
that obviously you guys like us
are completely aligned with but my
frustration with him at this point is i
want him to just say at this point he's
a libertarian basically just say it bill
you want to smoke pot
you want to live your life you're a
bachelor at 60 whatever with millions of
dollars and go to the playboy mansion or
whatever is left with it
uh yeah i know is there even a playboy
mansion left anymore uh you know yeah
somebody bought it and i don't know
what's going on there but but to me it's
like bill
is this odd thing where he'll bring on
adam schiff and say you know all my
friends are leaving and california is
not
not business friendly but then he'll
still support democrats and i'm i'm
struggling with that help me nick
so you know back in the 90s the first
time i interviewed bill maher for
reason has been around since 1968 i
joined in 1993.
i interviewed bill at some point in the
mid 90s and he was calling himself a
libertarian then he was not particularly
ideological you know he's not a
card-carrying member i don't think of
anything other than maybe peta to be
quite honest but
um what he meant by that was that he was
in favor of free speech he was against
censorship which is a huge thing i mean
people forget in the 90s
janet reno and bill clinton along with
all
you know major republicans like bob dole
if
anybody remembers him they were all
talking about censoring cable tv for
having too much sex and violence and
you know we were talking about like
basic uh basic cable
and he pushed back on that he was very
big in favor of free speech in favor of
kind of open sexuality which was kind of
forward back then avant
um and then he i think with bush
uh and then obama and then certainly
trump
he started rolling more with democrats
in terms of economic policy and so
you know i actually think and i'm happy
to talk about this more i think there
is a kind of you know i i consider
myself a libertarian without adjectives
i believe in what reason calls free
minds and free markets i
you know i want choice in everything you
know from abortion
to schools to food to you know marriage
whatever
um and um you know but there are people
on the right who are more
conservative and are libertarian in
spirit or in many policies people on the
left and i think
uh bill maher is pretty good there on
the left side of things
uh and his really important function now
is you know he is one of the few people
in a kind of you know major what's now
legacy media it's funny to think that
hbo
is actually kind of old school yeah um
you know but he was sticking up for
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression
and you know at one point in that show
he was saying like can we hold two
thoughts at the same time that
uh you know for instance that um we were
talking about
asian violence against asians in america
and he was like
yeah there could be some of that coming
out of covid but it's also that the
atlanta shooting was not that
and i like to hear that kind of stuff
you know from whether it's from the
right or the left like people who are
just saying
you know let's have a conversation that
is not simply
uh talking points or or you know slurs
like heidi heitkamp was tossing around
so it sounds to me like you'd kind of
love him to say he was a libertarian in
a way because it would be great for
libertarianism but on another hand he
serves as sort of function
as a as a remaining liberal let's say
i think so yeah and and you know i again
like right left libertarians like
somewhere sometimes you hear
conservatarians and left libertarians
and you know whatever
i'm i'm less interested in that and and
the slogans or or the labels and i'm
more interested in like when you see
people actually having conversations and
one of the great
virtues of his show i think real time
and before that politically incorrect
when it was on ibc and before that on
comedy central
was that it was a staging ground for
people who disagree with each other
getting to air their you know to have a
conversation or even an argument
for more than 30 seconds at a time one
of the things that i think you've done
in a host of other people is really take
advantage of
the space and time that youtube and
other platforms you know the blaze
actually is also
a fascinating network to me because it's
you know the one thing you can't
say about the blaze is that oh you know
they're they're they're only talking in
15 second sound bites uh you know like
cnm
msnbc or fox even you know like these
are
long shows that are taking advantage of
the time and space we have so more power
to bill maher for that
yeah all right so let's move off bill
maher for a moment i'm going to keep
working i'm going to keep nudging him
on my show that's that's my plan is just
to keep nudging him because it's like
the democrats when they come to cancel
him
i said this to him once when they uh at
an after party at real time
i said you know when they come to get
you one day it's going to be the left
not the right
yeah i think he knows that because i and
i think it was during the show
like a portion of that air because of
covet there were you know fewer gas than
no
after party or anything like that but he
was saying you know that like
when he goes places like people are
often afraid to speak up
even in private gatherings because if
you don't know everybody i mean it's
it's kind of like everybody's in the
mafia
and they're always figuring there's a
couple of you know federal agents who
are recording everything
so you don't say anything if you don't
know everybody what a what if
you know [ __ ] up world to be living in
like where we have
you know some time uh you know since the
early 60s we kicked free of all the
dumbest restraints
on free speech you know government
censorship you could publish
you couldn't uh legally publish lady
chatterley's lover
james joyce's ulysses henry miller's
tropic of cancer
allen ginsberg's howl before about 1960
without worrying about being dragged
into court
we got rid of all of that and then we
created the internet which is like an
infinite you know hard drive where you
can just load up everything you want
and we're arguing now about like you
know policing each other's speech in
such picky you in horrible ways
it's you know it's it's tragic there's
basically a protection racket and nobody
knows who's in it so everyone is sort of
hostage at some level all right so let's
just back up for a second when because i
do sort of consider you because of what
you do with reason and you've been doing
this for
for a couple decades now forever
basically um
although i am noticing you're wearing a
suede jacket today instead of your
trademark
leather jacket yeah you know i think of
suede and leather
as uh you know the same thing really but
uh this
is a jacket that my girlfriend got me
for christmas and i like it a lot and
you know i've been out in la for a while
i'm usually in in
new york or dc and it's kind of a cowboy
jacket so what the hell
people know that is nick gillespie
walking down the street um
but where did this all start with you
this idea of freedom
and liberty was this five-year-old nick
wanting to
play fairly with his friends and even
exchanges
i did go to uh catholic school so like
you you learn pretty quickly
uh that you know people want to impose
limits on everything and then you kind
of like you get tired of those limits
somewhat uh but
a lot of it i think is just kind of
dispositional i think people
some people are born wanting to be able
just to do what they want as long as
they're not hurting other people which i
think is
a kind of basic impulse that defines
libertarianism
or libertarian ideas i don't even like
to use it as a noun anymore i don't like
to say i
am a libertarian or there is a thing
called libertarianism
i think it's more directional i think
it's temperamental i think it's
you know do you think that people should
be given more choice more autonomy
more freedom in any given situation as
the default sometimes we override that
but in general it's like you know yeah
let's have more freedom
and i'm happy that my life i was born in
63 you know most of my life
in most big ways we have been getting
more and more free and i think that's
great economically culturally uh
individually lifestyle-wise and stuff
but a big part of it was actually my
brother
who's older than me i was born in
brooklyn but grew up in new jersey my
brother went to college at rutgers as i
did and
uh and uh he discovered reason magazine
in the bookstore and started sending it
home to me and i was like oh wow that's
really
interesting stuff the way they do
analysis of the
outcomes of policies as opposed to
simply the intentions
and a lot of times things are that are
done in the name of making people more
free or more equal or better off
end up having the opposite result and
that really spoke to me
um and basically by the time i got to
college i was calling myself libertarian
and then i went to i worked for a while
as a teen magazine editor a music editor
a music magazine editor and you know you
meet a lot of people there who are very
into free expression
uh particularly among teen stars you've
never met people who want to
you know have no no restraints put on
them whatsoever as
you know as corey haim or corey feldman
at least at that time i'm not sure if
those magazines are so into free
expression these days
no i they are certainly not and but in
any case
um you know i went back to grad school
for english and uh
cultural studies literary and cultural
studies in the late 80s and that was the
time when what we were calling it was
political correctness kind of what what
has become
wokeness uh woke activism and
i realized i needed an ideology because
i wasn't a conservative aesthetically or
personally or temperamentally and i
certainly wasn't a progressive because
these were people who really
started you know this was the beginning
of really clamping down on speech
and of using identity politics or
something like that to shut down
conversation rather than open things up
which i thought
you know that's why i wanted to you know
go into academia
and um and i i took libertarian thought
more seriously and that's
kind of and then i got a job working at
reason so
it's interesting because you mentioned
something about sort of how we're wired
or temperament and i do notice that one
of the reasons i love going to
libertarian talks and events and college
things and
yaf and all of those things and yao and
all those there's a lot of
y's in there but is that the general
disposition of people
because the default is i don't want to
control
everyone right the disposition is quite
pleasant
i mean there's very rarely can you
remember once going to a libertarian
event i mean yes they got the convention
with the naked guy but where it's like a
real
fire and brimstone like angry people
and i think that that's an important
piece of this which may be just sort of
how
we're wired i think uh well two things
one is you know libertarians believe
in what sometimes gets called the right
of exit
and so like if you you know you you have
a conference in las vegas or you know
washington dc or antarctica whatever
and then you start screaming and yelling
at people that they're going to go to
hell or that they're not allowed to do
what you want like
you know people leave that room and they
go out the hallway and start talking so
you know it works pretty well i think
for me one of the questions is
i don't think it's simply you know
you're either born this way or that way
i like lady gaga's music and i like the
idea when you know her concept of born
that way
you know makes sense for a lot of things
including i think broadly speaking
uh you know sexual orientation but
i want i'm in the business of wanting to
make more libertarians or make the case
that a libertarian world
is more is better it's you know it it
leads to better outcomes it's more fair
it's more innovative it's more
fun um and you are not constantly
spending you know 90
of your bandwidth on making sure that
you're not saying something
that is going to get you canceled or
yelled at or put in prison
um to me you know that's so i i'm
you know i'm glad to hear you talking
about how like libertarian events
are kind of fun to go to and stuff like
that i want to see us grow
uh both as you know as a cultural force
more than a political force because i
agree with
people like andrew breitbart that you
know politics is a lagging indicator of
culture
and what worries me is that over the
past you know
certainly over the past decade or so it
feels like we are
going backward things people are trying
to throw it i i it's like people are
throwing a weighted blanket
over everything in american culture you
know the economy
the culture itself etc and that really
really worries me
the weighted blanket is nice for the
first few minutes but three hours later
when you can't get up and it's only
three in the afternoon
it's a real problem it's like only old
scared anxious people need weighted
blankets and i'm glad that we have a
free market that you know provides
millions of different types of weighted
blankets with whatever you know
superhero you want embossed on it and
everything but
like i don't want to live in a world
where that you're you're spending the
first half of every day
fighting to get out from under the
covers so i want to bring up a
completely fictitious event because
obviously this didn't happen
but let's just say one of us had a party
a little bit after the election
and let's just say there were a bunch of
political people at this party and we
were sitting around a fire and let's
just say maybe there were a couple
joints being passed around and let's
just say some of the people voted for
trump and some of the people voted
for biden this of course is completely
fictitious neither one of us good
decent citizens law abiding would ever
do something like this and let's just
say
some of the uh the biden people were
feeling good and the trump people were
kind of feeling upset and let's just say
you and again this is completely
fictitious
actually said to everybody you know
maybe everyone needs to calm down
because this is just the cyclical
nature of politics and perhaps it was
just the weed talking
but do you really feel that way that
even now as you see what i think
and and if you take a different position
it's fine sure an administration that's
sort of out of control and now we're
going to expand the courts and all of
this stuff
do you still feel calm within that and
that's a little bit of the the previous
question just related to temperature no
no i i think it's great and the one
thing i want to point out
is you know of course in california
smoking weed
is legal which is something that it was
you know obviously was going to happen
when i started at reason in 1993 and
there was the first medical marijuana
vote a ballot initiative in california
in 96
which won overwhelmingly um you know you
knew
legal weed was going to come but it's
kind of amazing that it came
you know and it's it's in a a majority
of people in america live in states
where recreational weed
is legal um you know the drug war is
ending
and it's kind of phenomenal so it's you
know and that's like one of the
libertarians don't have a lot of wins
but this is something
the first issue of reason in 1968 you
know talked about
ending the drug war before richard nixon
had even escalated it in the very early
70s so
you know it's it's kind of good to step
back every once in a while and say like
you know what like
there's a lot of terrible stuff going on
but you know in many ways things are
pretty good
to your larger point i think what we
specifically
were talking about in a fictional
universe in that completely fictional
universe absolutely you know it takes
place on the other side of earth
you know a negative earth or something
counter earth um the food was delicious
though at that
uh i i seem to remember
looking at that and thinking wow in a
fictional universe i wish i could eat
that food in my
actual place no but um you know it it
had more to do with things about free
speech and where we were going because i
had written before
the election uh and this is something i
voted for joe jorgensen i
almost never vote i actually i've only
voted for a major party candidate
once in any election at any level that
was walter mondale in 1984.
um i don't know what i was doing it did
not go well no i yeah
now and you know and it's like i i think
what i liked about him was that he
said he was going to raise taxes to
close the deficit i was like okay that's
honest it's suicide but it's honest
but in any case i had written before the
election here here are 11 trillion
reasons
to be scared shitless about joe biden
becoming president because he
had offered 11 trillion dollars in
new spending um you know in his campaign
platform
and that's really bad because donald
trump had actually met
or under donald trump the budget had
already massively increased from when he
took office
obama things ratcheted up from you know
2009 his first budget year to him
leaving
bush you know had increased spending 50
percent we have to stop
spending so much money especially since
we're not paying for it
so i i'm not a fan of of joe biden
i do think that we still live in a world
of free speech i dislike very much the
way
um you know the social media platforms
the facebooks twitter youtubes
of the world are clamping down on speech
i think that's inarguable and we have to
scream bloody murder
and also build alternatives to that
let's talk about that in a second
yeah you're specifically i think joe
biden is delivering on exactly what he
promised
and that is a dark winter for america
on every level um you know he and and to
this point like i was just reading today
kamala harris has actually said
oh you know biden is so busy doing other
things he's not even going to get around
to
legalizing or descheduling marijuana at
the federal level
which is also something that was kind of
promised you know so it's like
yeah he's going to be spending tons of
money i mean we we are
busting the budget in a way that is
unimaginable we can't pay for it
bills come due every dollar the
government spends is one more
like it's a deeper finger in your pocket
that is squeezing you in places you
shouldn't be squeezed it all comes back
to bite us
um and joe biden is out of control in
that sense so do you think though the
inherent problem
with this when you when you talk about
11 trillion in spending or 2.2 increment
relief or any of this that the numbers
are so bananas they're so out of control
and it makes sense to nobody
we also know that the you know the
budgets come in in these papers that
look like this and nobody reads them and
all that stuff
but that it it simply is just not sexy
enough
like you could sit here and explain
perfectly why we can't keep
you know doing this and that eventually
we're gonna have to go to war because
we're in a mafia game
basically where and if you can't pay
which we obviously can't pay well then
you better have a bigger gun than the
other guy
and china might call in the debt one day
but it just isn't sexy enough
i think that that's a real issue and
again you know i'm i'm kind of like
in the persuasion game like i i know
what i believe so i don't feel a need to
express
myself with uh you know like and say i
am the true
scotsman i'm the true libertarian and
don't disagree with me otherwise you're
not real or anything like that what i'm
trying to do
is persuade people to have a different
view of the world one in which
individual and you know involuntary
individual freedom and voluntary
association
is at the center of everything rather
than kind of top-down coercive controls
of business of culture of life um and
yeah that's a real question and i think
one of the things that i'm trying to
talk about now more
in all of this spending is that you know
it's like
you know when when you're getting all of
your money from one guy
or from you know one source and it's in
you know the capital district i mean
we're in the hunger games here
you know where everything is being
funneled in from the you know the
provinces to the capital
and then they spit some of it back at
you that comes with a huge amount of
strings attached
and it gets complicated and you know and
it's just
freaking annoying and you know and
especially coming on the heels of the
pandemic
in california in new york the the two
states where i spent
most of the lockdown you know you have
two
mad men who were being hailed as you
know the great saviors of humanity
by the media by people you know by
politicians and their handlers and all
of that kind of stuff
gavin newsom and andrew coma have been
revealed to be terrible at what they do
and one of them is a truly
awful human being which was hiding in
plain sight wait which one which one uh
well you know what i'll let your i'll
let your listeners
uh decide i think i know which one
you're talking about but i'm honestly
i'm not sure
we don't have to choose they can both be
awful human beings as well as awful
leaders but you know what we're
witnessing now
is a historic moment that i think builds
on two decades of the government at all
levels trying to get bigger certainly
the federal government where
it's spending more money it's regulating
more things uh you know where
we go from a place where you know we
started the 21st century
not having to um you know like
you know not having to take our clothes
off when we go to the airport
you know and and now we are not only
doing that we're talking about seriously
discussing
having to show medical papers in order
to get on a freaking airplane
um you know this is serious stuff and
this is the ground upon which
i think we need to persuade people to
say you know you might want that
fourteen hundred dollar check you might
want thirty six hundred dollars to have
a kid
and by the way i just wanna say it is so
immoral
to have the government trying to dictate
you know how many
times you [ __ ] or how many kids you have
by offering you more and more money and
it's it's also unfair to people who
don't want kids
you know um but having said any of that
like what we need to persuade people
about or what i'm trying to do
is like the more money you get from a
place the more they own you
on some level and what i want is i'm you
know i'm not an anarchist i don't think
there should be no government
um i think there should be a strictly
limited government and a lot of what it
should do
apart from like general defense is you
know it should be helping people who are
poor or for whatever reason don't have
the resources to fully
um uh you know kind of engage or
participate in society
give give poor people a lot of money to
go to education
to figure out how to live their lives
and things like that but leave middle
class and upper middle class and rich
people
you know we can pay our own way um but
you know we now have a government that
is promising to be all things to all
people
and that you know that paycheck you know
that paycheck from the government
doesn't come free so so so with all that
being said and you mentioned you voted
for joe jorgensen and i had her on the
show
and we had a great conversation for an
hour and i don't know if you happen to
see the clip but she made a terrible
mistake at the end because she died
yes she flat out asked me if i was going
to vote for her
and my feeling was i had to make an
honest calculation that this was going
to be a close
election and that everything that you
just said about spending and a series of
other things i thought biden was gonna
usher in and wokeness and all of the
stuff
so my calculation was trump is the last
guy guarding the door so
so i had to tell her that and the clip
went viral and all that stuff
but but do you think that was a fair
estimation
when when you hear sort of libertarian
minded or or classical
liberal types make that move did that
seem sane to you even though you didn't
make the move
yeah i you know what i um i would never
uh hold you know a vote against a person
you know uh
and or let me put it this way like in an
american context
you know i i don't understand
um you know i vote for the person who i
think represents me and it's kind of
like you know i'm choosing a pokemon to
represent me in a
pokemon battle or something like that um
and i i just want to point out there at
the daily mail there is an incredible
photo uh of hunter biden in
a scene two women sitting on his body
and in the back
is a stuffed squirtle who is like a very
basic pokemon and i'm like wow that is
like squirtle
is wants to go back into his pokeball
and yeah but
um having said all of that i know i i
mean i i understand why
people of a libertarian or classical
liberal a conservative or even a liberal
uh bent voted for trump because i do
think biden is bad news uh you know
what's fascinating too is as
as we're doing more and more analysis of
the vote the
you know uh trump weirdly uh you know
picked up
more ethnic votes he picked up you know
more black votes he picked up more
hispanic votes
he picked up a lot of votes from women
as well as men of color and things like
that so like
there's something you know interesting
going on that we're not really talking
about because everybody's either
you know trump and the election was
stolen or biden and like let's not look
at any let's not look in the rearview
mirror because
where we're going we are you know we're
just spending money all the time
we can't talk about anything else um so
i think it's a rational
uh you know it was a rational position
for me
you know i'm coming at it from a
different angle and what i'm more
interested about is the outcome the kind
of like um
uh hulk gestalt um and i i was actually
hoping
uh to be honest that trump would win um
and that he would be hemmed in by
a democratic congress or or a mixed
congress
and that we would start getting towards
some of the stuff that he had said as a
as a president
um or as as a candidate in 2016
that would have reduced the size scope
and spending of government which i don't
think he really did
um so yeah without getting too lost on
trump i mean
my feeling also with him was that he was
almost as
libertarian as we were ever going to get
or at least anytime soon
meaning even though spending exploded
for sure he did cut taxes we didn't get
into new wars he did do some criminal
justice reform
like there was there was stuff there
choice which i think is really important
he was so terrible for me on immigration
which is a
like immigration and drug policy and
maybe school choice are the three things
that i care about the most
in terms of actual politics um you know
so he was bad on immigration it was bad
on free trade i think
and uh and it's interesting of course
that joe biden is not touching any of
the tariffs or any of the trade policy
he's also talking about changing
immigration stuff but you know as we see
uh biden is merely he's the latest
president which means that he's the
latest president to put kids in cages on
the border and all of that kind of stuff
you know the the the distance between
biden and trump
has been exaggerated by everybody
because everybody has a reason to do
that
but um yeah you know trump i i
one of the one of the things though that
i think trump supporters
um have to deal with too is that like
between
november and january 6th he
i mean he had a breakdown and the way he
acted
um i think is the reason why the
democrats now control the senator have
you know a basic like a slimmest of
working majorities there
um i think he did a real disservice
ultimately to the country i don't care
about the republican party i don't care
about the democratic party but like he
he ushered in a weird moment which
ultimately threw the the senate to the
democrats
i will go on record there dave and say
and this goes back to that you know
mythical fictional conversation where i
say hey you know there are ebbs and
flows of stuff
the democrats lost seats in the house
you know even as they maintain their
majority they will lose control of the
house of representatives in the 22
2022 election i think the republicans
will also likely gain back control of
the senate
because even though biden is you know he
is the rich kid who comes you know who
comes to a party and is by giving
everybody a bottle of cristal or
something like that
people don't like him and they know we
are living on borrowed time
democrats are not popular their agenda
is not popular uh you know the problem
is the republicans
you know what what we have almost in
every time people i think
let they didn't vote for trump who got
in totally fairly on the slimmest of
majorities what
what a brilliant campaign he ran but
they were voting against
hillary this time they were voting
against trump uh you know and i think in
2022
they're going to be voting against biden
and the democrats yeah all right
that's good news for the republicans
let's get back to the idea portion and
a little less in the the trump you know
machine and and the binding and all that
do you find that there's any meaningful
distinction between classical liberal
and libertarian
at this point i don't know uh you know
and you know when i
started at reason we were kind of like
some people were talking about you know
we need to take the word
liberal back because in the you know in
the 19th century and really starting in
the
sev i guess 17th century you know
liberal meant that you believe
that people should have more you know
freedom to decide what matters in their
own life and it was
you know it was a new kind of position
that came in
england and political philosophy after
you know killing the king and beheading
charles the first
and you had this brief flowering of
liberal political philosophy
uh which of course in the in the
immediate aftermath and this is worth
thinking about you know oliver cromwell
led a successful
civil war and revolution kills a king
you know one of the first times that
that had happened certainly in british
history
where people in the name of like uh of
enfranchisement of everybody or many
people chop off the king and replace
them with a commonwealth with the
republic
uh you know within a couple of years
cromwell was placing his son
as the next leader you know things went
bad pretty quickly by the end of the
17th century things were better
um you know but people were saying oh we
should reclaim liberal because it's our
word first and
you know and then we came up with
libertarian friedrich hayek famously
said libertarian is a [ __ ] term it
you know it's not a good descriptor um i
don't know
if there's a difference between
classical liberal and libertarian it
seems to me to come down to
that a lot of people who are more kind
of conservative in their personal lives
and personal choices but are libertarian
call themselves classical liberal it may
be also that
a number of libertarians and this
bothers me in a way that i get into
trouble with
libertarians over the past quarter
century
a lot of libertarians actually have
drifted into anarchism
which and they toggle back and forth
between saying like i'm a libertarian
because i don't believe in any
government which is not libertarianism
as i understand it it's anarchism
you know and so i'm good with
libertarian um
i don't know you know that there is a
strong functional difference between a
classical liberal and a libertarian
because
i think we both believe in some some
government
should be strictly limited should be
much smaller than what we do
and everything government does in my
view
and i think liberals agree with this
generally classical liberals
it should be done in a way to facilitate
people being able to participate more
fully in in society you know and it's
not about punishing people
for being successful for being rich for
being good looking for being talented
it's more about how do we
how do we raise up the people who need
help that's
that's the function of government along
with you know keeping our borders safe
by the way for the record i actually
don't think there's a really meaningful
distinction anymore the only reason i
even asked the question is because for
me
as someone that wrote a book defending
classical liberalism
for me to keep going out there and
saying i'm a liberal
or for bill maher even at this point to
keep saying i'm a liberal it's become so
confusing that
i i've always said from the beginning i
don't mind if someone calls me a
libertarian i don't good
yeah and you know and we're going
through these phases you recall back in
the 80s
and in 1988 george h.w bush
was able to you know get a rise out of
the crowd by uh
you know calling um mike dukakis
the l work yeah you know and stuff like
that and the idea liberal had become
polluted
and liberal has faded i mean because
people democrats either say i'm a
democrat or i'm a progressive
and i think to the extent that you know
democrats
there's a lot of centrist people in the
country i think you know
60 percent of people probably or
certainly 40 percent of people
are roughly in the middle and i think
there's a lot of classical liberal
libertarian belief there
you know they believe in leaving people
alone and
you know and and uh you know kind of
fiscal
responsibility fiscal conservativism
social liberalism
but the left and the democratic party to
the extent it gets captured
by progressives it's going to leave a
lot more people
looking towards the center and towards
kind of liberal
you know classical liberal libertarian
positions i keep saying it i think maybe
it's nuts but what you just described
there of sort of the live and let
live attitude i think i think that it's
probably i honestly believe this if
people could really understand the
issues clearly and not get lost
in the show i really believe that's
probably like 80 percent of the country
that
that may sound nuts but but i think it
is i'm curious though because you
mentioned the and cap thing and i'm sure
you know michael malus and i love having
him on the show
i think he's a great you know anarchist
thinker i
love intellectually that exercise of
like how
far we can do that thing to end up in
mad max
what is like the the sort of line for
you where it's like no no that's too far
you know it's for me it's more like i i
believe
in uh and this is popular among kind of
libertarians i believe in
transhumanism and life extension and
longevity so i'm you know i'm
hopeful that i'm going to live to be
like 200 years old you know i doubt it
but you know
a guy can hope right and um they're
working on it they're working on it
even if i live to be 200 i just don't
have the time to like start arguing
about
everything about okay this is how we get
the government out of this and this and
this
and like i'm in favor of that direction
i think in general the government
is not good at what it does um you know
it's either incompetent or ineffective
or inefficient
or it's or it's kind of villainous you
know one of the reasons you would ask
how did i become a libertarian and
part of it is after i graduated college
and before i got in the lucrative teen
mag business
i was i wrote for a bunch of newspapers
in new jersey i was a reporter
and i would always have to go to
planning board meetings and like you
know if you want to turn people into
libertarians like just busload school
you know bus
school kids to planning board meetings
where people
you know just the people in charge just
rail against anybody who had the
temerity to like improve their land you
know or their house without getting the
right permits and half of the
cases i saw like people didn't even know
like oh i needed to go to the city
council to
put up a fence or like to you know make
my house better
it's like screw you but um you know in
any case i just
i don't feel a need to have a
philosophical discussion about
everything i like the idea that in
general
the government should be doing less and
what it should be doing it should be
competent at it should be coming up with
good solutions and that's why i like
stuff like school choice where
you know if you let you know most school
funding is done at the local and state
level
if you took all of the money that a
state or school district spends per
student
and just gave it to the parents and said
okay you can use this wherever you want
you can go to the public school or you
can find a private school
you can teach your kid at home like to
me
that's a win um because it would allow
people more freedom and more autonomy
you know to an ancap i'm the problem
because i'm not saying you know what
it's got to be like rock and roll high
school you got to blow up vince lombardi
high at the end and it's got to be
on fire otherwise you know you're not a
real libertarian and i'm like
yeah okay you know i don't i it's just
like i've only got 200
years man you know i've only got 200
years
yeah or you could be debating with
elizabeth warren who doesn't want school
choice but sends her kids
to private now well this is you know one
of the one of the things that i hoped
the past
year and and i i don't you know and
we're coming out of it like you know
everybody's getting vaccinated and you
know and the rush to vaccination by the
way this is a great libertarian wing
a win you know where it's like you know
and this is something good that donald
trump did he said you know what
obviously the government isn't going to
come up with these vaccines so we're
going to give
you know what seems like a lot of money
you know several billion dollars
to you know companies to develop
vaccines compared to the
trillions of dollars that we have spent
on covet relief that is you know mostly
going down the toilet somewhere
uh you know it's like it's a real
bargain but like that's a kind of
libertarian solution where it's like
okay we're going to incentivize people
to do something that's for the public
good uh you know the rollouts have been
kind of screwed up partly because of
people like gavin newsom or andrew cuomo
you know but uh you know that's that's a
good thing to do as we're coming
out of the cove at lockdown i hope we
don't lose the lessons which is like
you don't want the government telling
you don't want the government
controlling
every aspect of your life even to the
point of saying you know what
you are an essential worker you are in
an essential business so
you know you're a clothing store screw
you you're locked down for three months
or six months
you are a pharmacy so you get to open
you know you for these hours you're a
liquor store
you know in new york city at first
liquor stores were not considered
essential
that got changed really quickly but you
know so like a liquor store but then
another type of store as opposed to
saying
you know what if you're following these
safety protocols because we're in a
public health emergency
anybody who's following these these
general rules they can do whatever they
want they can open their business how
they want et cetera
well the height of hypocrisy would be
that target and the big box stores
remained open but
if you were a small store that sells the
same stuff as target
you were closed i mean now you know for
i you know my
main uh domicile is i live in uh in
manhattan and lower manhattan not far
from a kmart
and like clothing stores all over the
city were closed down because they
didn't serve an essential function
kmart because it sells some food and it
has a pharmacy
was open so you know the last remaining
kmart i mean like
you know what you talk about mad max
yeah on thunderdome it's like the last
place where you could shop for clothes
in new york city for a number of months
was freaking kmart
you know and it's like yeah that's just
not fair you know it's just not
fair and it didn't do anything to
promote or preserve public health so
so so where are you at with ice well i
think i sense where you're at with the
vaccine but if you want to go on that a
little bit but but more so the vaccine
passport because this seems to be the
next
step in the liberty fight yeah i don't
like you know i i was relieved to see
uh that the uh you know the biden white
house has said
uh you know and this is only a few days
ago they said you know what we're not
going to be getting involved in a
vaccine passport we don't see a role for
the
the government to be administering them
so i'm glad to hear that
but is that do you see that as like kind
of a wink wink like yeah
because you guys all do it all you big
businesses and airlines and
that's you know that's an interesting
question and i'll get to that in a
second because they did also say we will
issue guidelines you know we're not
going to enforce anything but we're
going to issue guidelines and then you
start to say like okay dude these
guidelines
essentially become rules um and
this is uh for me a genuinely
interesting question you have a couple
of people like ron desantis
in florida and greg abbott and texas
kind of saying either you know
preemptively passing laws saying that no
business
can can enforce it can say you need to
be vaccinated to come in here
i have to say one of again coming out of
covet like so much stuff has kind of
gone
you know you know weird um where
uh you know before covid uh you know you
would have
businesses keeping people out and then
you know and conservatives would be
cheering them like
you know don't don't force gay or cake
bakers
to to you know bake gay wedding cakes
right and you know
um and conservatives were like yes and
now they're kind of cheering on like
governor government saying to businesses
no you can't run your business the way
you want
because it's perceived as in the
conservatives interest
to block passports i think this will
shape well
i hope it will shake out where some
businesses will want to
say you know no shot no shirt no service
um and i think broadly speaking they
should be allowed to do that
um i think you know other stores that
want to say hey you know what
you know don't you don't need a shot um
you know don't cut you don't need to be
a shot
you don't need shirts and you don't need
the shoes you know whatever
i think it's a better world when we
allow everybody to set their own rules
and then you know live with the
consequences of that
yeah so but so the passport issue though
i i do
you know again it's um i don't like the
idea of the
i don't i don't like the idea of the
government
setting these really strict terms for
like you walking around in public
what does it mean that we'll have like a
passport vaccine is it the type of thing
where police
will be able to kind of stop you on the
street and say like hey have you been
vaccinated or not and even if
even you know is it going to become kind
of like the stop and frisk
you know for for coronavirus or
something like that
you know if it becomes something like
that i think everyone will be against it
um
i don't know you know and then you have
these weird intermediary things like
well what about airlines because some
airlines and some foreign airlines are
already starting to develop
like you got to show that you've been
vaccinated before you can get on the
flight
for a domestic flight you know i don't
think so the other thing is that
a lot of this stuff is all um it's a way
of smuggling
in control of people's lives in the name
of public safety and public health
yeah and that we need to stand a thwart
this is something that michelle foucault
the
left-wing french social theorist thomas
saws
you know a hardcore libertarian critic
of medicalization of
all parts of american society they would
agree appeals to public health
oftentimes don't have anything to do
with public health it's about
controlling people's behavior
and making them live the way you want to
so as you're watching this happen and
the states do their own thing
is it giving you some sense of
satisfaction in a way because it's like
oh
this is how the system was supposed to
work as long as as long as the feds
don't do
what they're saying they're not going to
do that letting florida make its choices
and
you know guys like us that are from new
york and new jersey and live in
california it's like you got to live
with your choices man
uh yeah no and you know and to the
extent that you know you have more
options to sort
so you know i'm a big believer there's a
guy named albert hirschman a political
scientist in the early 70s wrote a book
called
exit voice and loyalty and he said you
know there are basically three ways to
register
uh dissent from the status quo and one
is loyalty which where you just give up
and you become a company man and you do
what you're told and you know learn to
love it
um that is not very appealing to most
people there's a voice where you work
within the system for reform
and you scream bloody murder when you're
pissed about something and that's
whether you're a facebook user or a
resident of you know arkansas or alaska
or alabama
and then there's exit where you pull up
stakes and you go out on the frontier or
you leave and you go someplace more to
your liking or
you know kind of what you have done with
your show you know and you exited the
young turks you went to new places
you know and when youtube gets too hot
for you you know you you form a
partnership with the blaze you create
locals all of that kind of stuff you do
exit where you go to a place that's more
hospitable or you create your own kind
of moon colony you know which is kind of
great
and so that's the dynamic that should be
at work here as much as possible
i do find it you know it's just that the
the hypocrisy or the bad faith arguments
i think in a lot of
people where ron desantis you know he
was the number one grandma
killer because he was letting people do
their build a lot of ground
yeah and then it but it hurts to see him
now being like okay you're a business in
florida
you can't you know you can't decide how
to run your business because i'm telling
you you cannot block somebody
like yes i'm with you if you don't want
to bake a cake for somebody because you
don't like how they [ __ ]
but like god damn it i'm going to put
you in jail if you insist on a
covet vaccination like do you see what
they were just more systematic
yeah so i'm with you on that but do you
i to me i can grant him a little
extra leash there because to me it's
like an over correction because they've
all gone
so insane so then he's saying something
that it's
like a little over the top but it's sort
of it's directionally right and i can
kind of get over it
you know i think this is one of the
limits of sometimes when i think about
okay what what is what are libertarian
ideas how do they affect
society and it's that you know we're
never going to live in
we're never going to live in an ancap
society in a narco-capitalist society
we're not going to live in a libertarian
society but what we do is we kind of
you know we add spice or we give a
direction that people slowly kind of
ooze over to
um and and that's okay but i you know
we're bad at being tribalistic and it is
like so
i'm with people i'm with politicians
right up until the moment that they
contravene a principle and this is why
people like ted cruz
is a good example in the us senate where
he came into office you know as
a tea party darling and he's he had a
good rhetoric
from a generally speaking limited
government libertarian-ish
perspective but he just is constantly
arguing in bad faith and flip-flopping
you know because
at every moment like if you're part of a
tribe if you're a republican it means
at a certain point your principles stop
and and party affiliation takes over and
like
i can't really go there and i think it
might mean you know this is why
certainly the libertarian party but i
think more broadly libertarians
will you know we are important and we're
vital to a flourishing america but we're
never
you know we're never going to have a 60
plural or majority in anything
right and by the way that's why i like
talking about ideas way more than
politics because
yes politics just just kind of make you
crazy in case
people don't ideas again well you know
but what worries me and i know this is a
concern of yours is that
you know so let's say you know uh
breitbart would say that politics is
downstream from culture i talk about
politics as a lagging indicator you know
we've had when it comes to things like
free speech
we've had a supreme court that for the
past 25 or 30 years
actually more like 50 years has been
really great on free speech and
every time including going back to the
mid-90s when
uh the clinton administration and
republicans in congress
wanted to regulate the internet like a
broadcast network under the
communications decency act
the supreme court in a nearly it was
like a seven to two decision
said no this is an illegal abridgement
of the first amendment of people's
freedom to speak et cetera
we have a good supreme court we have a
culture of free speech which has
degraded
so much over the past 25 years you know
the supreme court there's a joke
you know that the supreme court reads
the newspaper it's like we've
we've been lucky to have the supreme
court knocked down a lot of restrictions
on speech now we're living in a
a real battleground where people are
saying you know what certain sp
speech is offensive this speech is
threatening if speech
makes me feel unsafe we got to get rid
of it and they're
they're turning the screws on all of the
places where we can speak
you know and how much longer like uh
clarence thomas recently
in a dissent in a recent case was saying
you know what like maybe we should be
regulating
facebook and other social media as a
common carrier it's like you know as
abc and nbc news as you know as you know
where they can't moderate any content
and i'm like holy cow this is this could
be the beginning of a really bad period
for the not just the law of free speech
but the culture of freedom
okay so that's exactly you got me to
exactly where i wanted to spend our last
couple of minutes which of course is the
big tech thing which
i think for many libertarians has pushed
their libertarian beliefs
to the to the end of the line it's sort
of a rubber meet road
moment so so i'm with you and the
clarence thomas thing is really
interesting because i understand the
inclination
and then on the other hand it's like
well wait a minute then if you start
regulating them don't you just kind of
keep them around forever much like abc
and cbs and nbc interesting right so
yeah so where
are you on big tech at this point
because the main line that i hear every
time you put out a libertarian idea on
big tech
okay build your own internet and then
they're gonna blow up your servers so
help me out
and you know i'm working on a piece
that'll come out down the road a little
bit but of like you know parlor
did exactly what they were told you know
if you don't like it and this is where
liberals and progressives who were
telling the cake baker
you got to bake the damn cake and then
they're saying to
you know so they're saying no you can't
leave nobody you know you you are forced
to do this
then when it's when it's a conservative
saying i want this then they're like
well build your own internet you know
and parlor did all of that and at every
step
you know they were being [ __ ] blocked by
anybody who could you know whether it
was amazon web services
uh you know payment uh payment programs
uh you know app stores
um and yet they persisted and they're
still out there and this
i think this will be unsatisfying to you
i think we are in a place where
you know we need to say if you believe
in private property rights and ownership
and things like that that facebook
does have a right to run its service the
way that it wants to
uh and this is going back to the
hirschmann stuff of you know exit voice
and loyalty
i'm not being loyal i'm not loyal to
facebook i'm not loyal to almost
anything you know other than principals
so like i'm not going to go along with
whatever facebook wants i'm going to
scream bloody murder on facebook on
youtube
in the internet you know at twitter uh
which did an abominable thing
last you know last fall when they
blocked the new york post story
about hunter biden and joe biden before
the election it's like insane i was like
apoplectic uh you know and they did
kind of walk it back a little bit but
it's a constant fight because every time
you turn your back they're trying to
turn down
a little bit more sphere of free speech
well now we're seeing hunter biden bang
this girl with charmander sitting next
to him
who was it not charmander squirtle i
would have i it was squirtle i would
have thought it was
he would have i thought charmander you
know but now
you would think he'd be a charmander guy
but he's squirtle which is just too much
to think about
it's too on the money yeah yeah but um
uh but you know
you have to scream bloody murder and
then you also have to be constantly
building alternatives and you know one
of the things that i like
is that you know just as twitter is
getting
worse um you know in terms of it's you
know it's arbitrary it's ideological
it's politically correct
you know suddenly clubhouse appears as a
place where you can have
free more free and open and different
types of discussions
then you see people starting to move in
there saying like you know what the
problem with clubhouse is nobody's
recording and reporting on everything
everybody's saying
it's unfettered that's what they said in
the new york times
unfettered you know could you i mean
like my grandparents all left
ireland and italy to get out of fetters
like nobody wants
fetters you know for christ's sake but
you know and so clubhouse you can
already see the beginning of the end of
clubhouse but there'll be something
there after that
and it's a push pull where you know you
it's
it's it's not a um utopian
or like super idealistic or
inspirational outcome but i think
between
voice and exit and a constant pushing
that's where freedom is going to resolve
and i'm
a big fan of a concept that was popular
in the 90s called temporary autonomous
zones and these were places where
you know outside of you know the church
outside of the government outside of
school
you would find these little places where
for a little while
you could do or say or be whatever you
wanted to be you know and burning man
was
like a big example of that especially
before burning man
it's not that it's corporate but you
know it's it becomes its own institution
and it's
it's more fettered yeah um but that now
there are a million other face
burning mans and whatnot and i think
this has to be like what we have to
strive for
is to say you know what in my life um
and in everything i do i'm going to be
tolerant i'm going to be pluralistic i'm
going to engage people
rather than try to shut them down and
cancel them and screw them over
and not only make sure that they're not
doing well but that anybody who
associates with them gets put in the
gulag you know figurative as maybe
um we have to model that and then we
have to constantly be
building the escape hatch you know
building the escape pod and having
you know the figurative equivalent of a
swiss bank account
where we can go and have the
conversations uh the lives that we want
um and and what's great about that is
that you know
for all of this you know abc nbc cbs
they still exist
and they still draw big numbers but
everybody's kind of drawn to
the frontier where things are a little
bit newer things are a little bit more
free
things are a little bit more current um
and
you know that's the dynamic that i think
people need to understand
and we need to make sure that that you
know kind of yeah i think that in a lot
of ways that for me is what american
exceptionalism is is this
balance between being rooted in a
community and caring about people
and then also being ready to light out
for the territory when
you know this this thing here that we
grew up in whether it's new jersey or
new york
or wherever you know it gets a little
bit too stuffed up it gets a little bit
too repressive
we're gonna light out for someplace else
nick you just gave me like a
three minute sort of atlas shrugged
ending
sales job for locals because that's
exactly what i'm trying to do with
locals we're building my escape hatch
while i'm yelling and
yeah i know and and you know it's funny
because i know a bunch of people who are
using it
and they all say the same thing and and
where you guys at locals are doing it
right
and i think this is also starting to
happen in social media
where it's decentralized so that it is
you know like there is no one choke
point because this is also
true you know when it comes to
everything that depends on a credit card
you know payment or something like
there's a choke point everything where
there's a central server
there's a choke point where one person
ultimately
you know there's the button the on off
switch and they can flip it one way or
the other
the future is much more dispersed and
decentralized and
we need to be promoting that not simply
as like okay this will do but like
that's what we want you know we you know
and it's it's always better
you know this may seem far afield but
like
intersectionality which has become a
buzzword in identity politics you know
the way i see it or the way i interpret
it it's that
all of us are made up of like partial
identities and and
interests and things like that and no
one of them defines
us fully but overlapping they kind of
give us a sense but they also make us
more resilient
they make us less fragile because you
know we have a lot of different parts of
our lives going on and that's it's a
kind of way of decentralizing dispersing
who we are it's um like you know
horcruxes and
it's like a horcrux in harry potter
where what you know you want to have
parts of your soul all over the place so
that you can't get wiped out of one you
know
because of one bad action or one big
mistake or one big attack
um that's what our society has to be
like and i in a lot of ways i think
we're groping towards that and that's
actually if i may that's what drives me
nuts about political correctness or
tribal politics whether it's right-wing
or left-wing
where people want to take all of the
complexities of all we do and all
who we are and say no you know what you
are this one thing
whether it's you're this religion you're
this gender you're this orientation
you're this profession like no way man
you know what was great about the 20th
century
which was a miserable century you know
my father like i said my father fought
in world war ii
there were mass exterminations you know
the russian gulag all of that
it ended in this furious you know kind
of
fireworks show of mass personalization
mass individualization
and then that all you know kind of came
crashing down and like
we've got to get out of the rubble of
the global war on terror we've got to
get out of the garrison state of
government getting so big i mean you
know
biden is talking you know we've got the
we have the rescue plan which was 1.9
trillion we've got 2.2 trillion dollars
in infrastructure
which people are saying you know child
care is infrastructure you know
toothpaste is infrastructure
and then then he's got like another two
and a something trillion dollar plan
just down the road like you know we
gotta we gotta leave that behind and
and you know start getting down to
living our lives rather than waiting for
checks
you know from that that we can't afford
nick you gave me
two atlas shrugged endings there very i
guess oh yeah yeah
and yeah and i will i will uh admit that
i've never read atlas shrugged i've
never finished it
i've watched the movies which i enjoyed
and i know the basic plot
and i kind of like the idea of gold's
gulch but i also worry that galtz gulch
would be like the worst homeowner
association
well that's what no you can only even
you know everybody's armed
right so it's like okay i mean i i guess
i believe
like robert heinlein and william
burroughs both said that uh
an armed society is a pleasant society
but i don't know if i would want to live
in gold's culture i think
i would want to have a friend who has a
condom or a time share there
listen i i cannot believe we did not do
this
in all these years so i i really enjoyed
this and let's just say
let's just say i was hypothetic oh i've
said too much
let's just say someone was
hypothetically going to have some sort
of get together which
with a bunch of political dissidents and
sit around a fire and smoke some weed
in the next couple days uh would that be
something that would hypothetically
interest someone like
you know that is hypothetically uh yes
it's always
it's always fascinating and uh you know
the only thing better than potential
is uh you know is then potential energy
is uh you know real energy right so
nick i will hypothetically see you on
friday night and we'll link to all your
stuff down below and it was good seeing
you man
thank you so much if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell